a Senate vote on the republican party's
signature health-care legislation is on
hold
GOP leaders are now regrouping after the
boat was delayed until at least the
middle of July President Trump is
pushing GOP senators to quote do
something very very important for the
people of our country he brought them to
the White House yesterday to try to
bridge Republican differences
Marco Brennan is at the White House with
the administration's efforts to try and
close the deal Margaret good morning
good morning well President Trump
considers himself a closer but his
deal-making has been ineffective in the
Senate where Republican leaders bowed to
pressure from within their own party and
postponed a health care vote until
sometime after the July 4th recess so
we're gonna talk and we're gonna see
what we can do
president Trump summoned all Republican
senators to the White House for an
emergency meeting Tuesday after party
leaders postponed the health care vote
due to a lack of support this will be
great if we get it done and if we don't
get it done it's just gonna be something
that we're not going to like and that's
okay and I understand that very well
some senators arrived back to Capitol
Hill optimistic they will find a path to
passage we're not there yet others are
less confident this president is the
first president in our history who has
had neither political nor military
experience and thus it has been a
challenge to him to learn how to
interact with Congress mr. Trump
downplayed their dissent in a Twitter
post saying that Republicans are working
hard and really want to get it right but
his aides worked furiously to turn the
tide vice president pence a former
congressman lobbied the entire
Republican caucus at their weekly lunch
while White House chief of staff Reince
Priebus and press secretary Sean Spicer
also worked Capitol Hill I think we've
got a really good chance of getting
there it'll just take us a little bit
longer Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell must now try to resolve his
own party's concerns or be forced to
find hard to win Democratic support
we'll have to sit down with Senator
Schumer and my suspicion is that any
negotiation with the Democrats
would include none of the reforms that
we would like to make during yesterday's
White House meeting a number of
Republican senators complained about
President Trump's supporters running
attack ads against one of their own a
pro Trump political action committee has
been running this ad against Nevada
senator Dean Heller after he opposed the
health care bill and that strategy
backfired Heller personally complained
about the ads and shortly after the
meeting the group agreed it would stop
running them Gayle thank you very much
Margaret